[Music]
the
[Music]
ruling establishment
is really really turning up the dial on
the propaganda to a way that would be
really funny if it weren't so sad
you may have noticed at some
public events recently there has been an
uncouth chant that has this is sporting
events
concerts
and what people are chanting is
f joe biden and they chant this a lot at
all these sorts of events and it seems
to happen out of nowhere and you've been
hearing it for weeks now so
nbc shows up nbc sports shows up to a
nascar race all right nascar
probably not filled with the highest
percentage of biden supporters of any
event in the country and they're
interviewing one of the drivers and in
the background
you can hear
this chant cropping up as it has in a
lot of places and the reporter refuses
to ignore the chant but also refuses to
acknowledge the chant instead the
reporter chooses to rewrite the chant
thank you to all of our partners
oh my god it's such an unbelievable
brandon you also told me
you can hear the chance from the the
crowd
let's go brandon you told me you were
gonna kind of hang back those first two
stages and just watch and learn what you
learned that helped you there in those
closing laps oh my god it was uh
learning how
line didn't
stay to one everything shifted top to
bottom
do you think they were saying
let's go brandon
i look i don't have the best hearing
okay but i didn't hear let's
le i mean because i agree i believe that
brandon should go go himself i agree
i i
whatever they were chanting i think i
agree with that so if it's let's go
brandon sure brandon go go yourself go
go yourself brandon but i don't think
that's exactly
what they were saying and what's so
offensive about it
is that
i i don't think this woman's hearing is
clogged any more than ours is she heard
what they said and she rewrote it
and she's looking at all of you you
can't see her on camera but she is
effectively looking at all of you and
saying hey that thing you just heard you
didn't really hear it
that thing that you're hearing right now
behind me that undeniable loud thing
that a crowd of people is screaming yeah
they're not really doing that
no no you know what they're saying
they're saying let's go brandon
yeah that's right that's the ticket
let's go brandon
if
the press are lying to you about this
what else are they lying to you about
this is like that thing drew clavin
points this out a lot you open up the
newspaper and you say oh syria okay and
this is what's happening in syria okay
that's fine i believe that and oh hey um
taxes yeah okay that's what's happening
in taxes okay i believe that and oh hey
the yankees and wait a second that's not
happening with the yankees no it's not
whatever this reporter's writing isn't
true and i know that because i follow
the yankees
okay well time to oh healthcare policy
okay that's what's going on in
healthcare so you know on the one thing
you know about you know the press is
lying but then you go ahead and you
believe them
on all the other topics that you don't
know anything about why there's no
reason to believe they're any more
trustworthy there than they are
here if they're going to lie to you
about what someone is chanting directly
behind their heads
that you can see you can see their
mouths moving for goodness sakes
they're going to lie to you about
anything that serves their political
advantage i'm glad you liked that clip
get the whole show either here at the
michael knowles show on youtube or at
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcasts type
it in the michael knowles show subscribe
click that button we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]